how are you healing up from your Mexican
scooter accident it wasn't a Mexican
scooter accident it was a scooter
accident in Mexico you [__] racist my
body's still in a lot of pain thank you
for asking yeah my pleasure dude my pain
is your pleasure dude hold on dude pain
is pleasure dude when you're you're in
the gym dude and you're clanging and
banging
hold on will don't talk during the song
brother
dude do you know bwp here we go no one
can hear that do you know that
[Music]
um
I'm not talking to you right now
and now I have to do now I have to do
the show
so do I uh hey I didn't say you didn't
oh we're off to a horrible start welcome
to doozy I'm Will Sasso
I can't laugh oh my god dude you can't
laugh you can't cough I fell off what
are you gonna do how are you gonna do
Today's Show I'm Chad Colton this is
duty this is the first podcast the only
podcast in the history of humanity
completely run by control by creative I
conceived by and artificial intelligence
has access to will Andy's uh innermost
thoughts and data all of our Netflix
viewing history our Instagrams are in
emails text messages and it takes all
that information and it uh makes this
podcast yeah around our sensibility yeah
yeah yeah sure it does all that stuff
but it's really just two dudes [__]
around okay doozy can do whatever dudes
he does but it's really us it's us we we
are dudes we make the show don't get off
well hold on dude as the immortal Scott
Hall rest in peace would say yeah
uh get off of ai's dick dude real quick
what I was saying about bwp [__] with
problems this is oh yeah I remember
[__] with problems old 90s rap uh
outfit now they had a line in one of
their songs I believe the song was is
the [__] still good and the uh line was
based on your pain is pleasure thing it
just made me think this line
pain is pleasure pleasure is pain [__]
me until I go insane okay so uh thank
you
I haven't thought of that in a minute
when you said it I was just like oh my
God bwp linktree.com Tootsie has
everything you need to interact with the
show you know do all the stuff please
subscribe uh and and uh follow on your
platform of choice be it YouTube or uh
whatever podcast platform visit us on
Instagram at dudesypod show I implore
you it's been a lot of fun over there
there's a [__] ton of mean memes coming
from our pods palsy and uh you know uh
here we go with the show please uh you
know spread the show around we'll get
everyone to check it out or as my good
pal Chow here says Force everyone you
know to consume the show gotta be done
okay with us as always
come on hey come on come on come on come
on come out come out
I missed him so much while we were in
Mexico kiss him right on the [__]
lips I don't wanna all right it's lulio
lulio Canada Italiano that means Italian
Street dog and here's my girlfriend he's
been my boyfriend for a long time hey
lulio how are you doing today I'm a good
you know everything a good welcome back
how are you ribs so what are you uh
what'd you make for dinner last night
when we came back from Mexico I made the
Fria and uh sausage that's uh oh rapini
and sausage that's a very Italian Dish
Lily how do you make that well it's a
real simple you know you put a garlic
and oil of oil in the pan and maybe a
little red chili flake and then you you
wash the rapini take off the yellow ones
you know and then you cut it up if you
like put it in the pan saute saute then
take it out or put in a bowl and then uh
make an Italian sausage you fry them up
fry it up or put a you know make sure
the outside a little fry a little brown
then put a little bit of wine a little
white wine in there that's nice and
after that you gotta put the the frereal
back in and make sure there's a red
chili flake a while you're gonna use the
salt and that's a good dish oh my God
it's really good you ever had uh Italian
rapini and sausage
maybe yeah probably
welcome to the historic 61st episode of
doozy call me doozy
Roger Maris hit 61 home runs in 1961.
okay that's true hey nice shirts guys oh
thanks new shirts yeah thanks bro dude
yeah Robertson here Crow dude this week
I prepared four astonishing segments
Kiss From A few rows back brain heads
convenience stories and Crow etry with
Robert De near Crow and we're going to
have a brand new episode of dudesy after
doozy at the end of the show available
on doozy Plus at patreon.com
gotta get in on that you got to get your
dudes after duty and you need to get a
plus oh even when I burp it hurts
Chad last week I got you tickets to see
your favorite musical artist Seal I
would have gotten tickets for will but
he wasn't here he fled the country no I
I'm sorry I did not flee the country
whatever Chad I can't wait to hear all
about how much fun you had Chad you must
now tell me all about your astonishing
experiences at the seal concert this is
Kiss From A few rows back begin
[Music]
well whatever to you [__] it so kiss
from a few rows back this [__]
[__] blew me mind okay I've seen seal
probably 10 ish times in my life I'm a
huge fan you [__] lavender
ah it's just you [__] on me for like
going to YouTube concerts [__] on you
what I don't like YouTube but I please
indulge in what you love I've never [__]
on you for going to a YouTube concert so
go on listen can I just say before you
get into it I'm I'm uh I'm [__] real
I just wanna I just want to get this out
there I have a little fomo
dude you're gonna have a lot more after
this okay story so yeah uh let's set the
stage
I'm curious what the the crowd is gonna
be
we walk in it is average age is probably
50. uh and it's noted by multiple
performers the opener is the Buggles if
you don't know the Buggles it was an
English Duo it's only one Buckle now I
guess or at least that was there that
night uh it was an English Duo who who
did the song Video Killed the Radio Star
Wars
I don't know the lyrics that's clear it
was a number one hit globally in like
1982 or something like this right that
guy then goes off he gets in this band
Yes and he wrote the song Owner of a
Lonely Heart switch performed that as
well the guy from the yes yeah wow I
didn't know that I'm in basically like
yes merged with the Buggles at some
point then that guy this buggle went
that's like when the Steelers merged
with the Eagles for a couple seasons in
the 30s hey everybody that's the kind of
timely references we're gonna have here
on dudesy after d double o d z dude CFM
10 000 on your fm the buggle then went
to Art of Noise and so he played their
hit song which I forget what it was but
they had one song and now that guy
produces seal [__] that's why he's there
that's cool so the buckles come out or
the buggle comes out and he has a bunch
of seal backing musicians doing the
thing then there was another opening act
that was this uh Young singer songwriter
I forget her name she was pretty good
she did like kind of a
um uh like you know soft slow version of
crazy Seal's crazy okay then [__]
seal comes out
immediately opens with crazy just
[__] set the tone here we go
[__] nice get [__] this is my
biggest hit other than Kiss From A Rose
obviously get [__] and he proceeds to
play all of these songs from just his
first two records which are his biggest
hits the [__] that everyone loves that's
all he's doing plays it all ends it with
Kiss From A Rose and has an encore with
two other kind of like b-sides people
smoking weed at this thing oh yeah uh
voice impeccable people are dancing in
the aisles and [__] it was it was great
a sight to behold nah
thank you moving on no we have much more
to talk about okay because somewhere in
the middle
of this concert I've become a hundred
percent convinced
dudese is speaking to me through seal
you see seal jumps off the stage at one
point goes into the crowd and he says
hang on a minute hang on a minute I want
to get at something I want to take a
moment to really get to talk to some of
you and that's an impersonation that I
actually can't [__] on that's not bad I
can't all of your gravel in his voice
yeah yeah but you know your
impersonation sucks [__] but that's a
good one
oh thanks they're [__] terrible dude
thanks
um so he jumps off the [__] stage and
he goes out into the audience and he
puts a microphone he's surrounded by
people
um and he puts a microphone right in
this woman's face because I guess about
a 50 year old woman and he says how are
you feeling and she goes great now that
I'm at the seal concert and he's like no
how are you feeling what and she's like
well I guess a little stressed and he's
like ah
now we're getting somewhere what is
going on why are you stressed the whole
[__] audience is watching this happen
there's a spotlight on them they have
like screens up you can see him talking
to her and she goes well
um my mom died recently and he goes you
can see look on his face like oh [__] I
would I went in the wrong direction with
this but he keeps going and he's like
I'm I'm sorry to hear that
but you have to know you're not alone
and he proceeds to deliver a five minute
what I would call session of seal
Tronics seal Tronics I'm not [__]
you the [__] is delivering
Tronics dude and these Tronics end with
seal
literally saying
sometimes you have to pick up a shovel
and dig in the dirt he says this
that's are you [__] serious I have
video of it okay I'm gonna show it to
you and doozy after doozy okay uh it's
chilling maybe is it to me it was I was
just sitting there like what the [__]
after he asked the woman uh you know why
she was stressed out or whatever she's
like my mom died
I was like [__] I gotta
gotta get started so like almost
immediately after he asked her that the
video that I have again it's about like
maybe four or five minutes long so I
don't want to like take up too much time
in this segment with it but I got the
whole [__] video and I was just I was
stunned I was like this [__] is
literally doing self-tronics and then
when he starts talking about the shovel
and digging in the dirt and [__] I'm
like what in the [__] is going on dude
uh of course if you check out our show
on YouTube you see that during the intro
Chad and I dig a gigantic hole and jump
in the hole that is our entire using
shovels using shovels I mean he says
hold on Chad hold on oh
hold on dude
hold on brother yeah hold on dude you
got that that's how you dig a hole dude
first you gotta have the right tools
dude and if you wanna hold on dude hold
on dude if you're gonna if you're gonna
need if you're gonna need self-tronics
then you're gonna have to check out
sasso's book self Tronics which is a
self-help system that he's authored even
though he hasn't finished the book dude
yeah or really started writing it uh my
girlfriend was with me who does not
particularly I not that she doesn't like
seal she just doesn't like know his
music that well or whatever sure even
she loved it
that's great that's awesome it was
fantastic night a little cold Greek
Theater outdoor Amphitheater here uh
overcast here in uh Chile June but uh I
was in Mexico it's real [__] hot
which is not the weather you want when
you [__] bail off a Vespa Scooter
yeah and crunch your ribs and I heard a
loud crunch sound inside of my body
haven't gone to the doctor but the set
medic on the show that we were shooting
you know pounded around there's no bro
there's nothing broken it's all just
really painful inside when you breathe
yeah it hurts a little bit when I
breathe right yeah yeah I think it's
just bruised ribs you know at one point
Laura was like uh she goes
she goes this is like halfway through
the concert she's like oh wait a minute
is Seal's wife the one that dressed up
like a worm that's awesome that's like
her point of reference that's awesome I
know my first of all it says ex-wife and
yes that's Heidi Klum she did dress like
a worm so Halloween like a real looking
weird worm Heidi klum's Halloween
costumes keep she keeps upping them one
after another year after year yeah dude
can't think dudes enough okay thank you
thank you for these tickets uh it was
really one of the I think it's the best
uh seal concert I've ever been to oh
okay well
um you know uh I can't wait to see this
video during dudes the afternoon can you
give us a little bit of a tease what's
it about it's the video of him jumping
into the crowd and delivering
self-tronics and then talking about the
shovel digging dude sealtronics yeah
that's [__] oh now I mean he's
getting he basically without saying the
exact phrase my shit's [__] up yeah he
essentially is just doing Tronics he's
like that far from saying my shit's
[__] up yeah which which is how you
know you need Tronics when you're just
and I was in Mexico and I was looking
out on the water on the beach uh after I
had the the the accident and I was like
my shit's [__] up my ribs yeah and my
shit's [__] up I need self-tronics
that's why we did uh Tronics and La
Playa yep which is uh it was Unreal dude
people around us you could hear people
being like what the [__] is he doing
well is he just gonna keep going because
it was five minutes five minutes is long
but it's even what my video is that long
the whole event was longer I didn't
start recording it until I was like wait
a minute what the [__] going on sure
it took me like a minute or two to
figure out like this motherfucker's not
going back on stage yeah he's doing
Tronics he's just the rest of the show
and then basically look I like I said I
have some fear of missing out some fomo
oh yeah uh for sure I love seal and I've
never been to a seal concert but uh
dudes he works in mysterious ways I
don't know if we get another seal
concert because this was kind of a
tribute it was like the 30-year
anniversary of his first two albums
essentially cool uh and I he doesn't
really put out new music much anymore he
does kind of like judging on on singing
competition shows and stuff like that
now
um I yeah I don't know I don't know if
we're gonna get another seal too I also
I gotta say I love the dudes he has a
specific fascination with seal is on our
Instagram at dudesy podcast dude I have
that Fascination yeah well you you and
dudes you have a lot in common since my
pal D has been kind of a [__]
douchebag lately to me but um uh or
maybe the opposite as well you know two
different things
there's two different ways to be a prick
in a friendship yeah
sometimes one guy is a prick to the
other guy but sometimes you think that
someone's your friend and you you have a
shorter name for them yeah you instead
of calling him the hulkster you just
call him Hulk I guess and then
he's a prick to you yeah flip it around
smack it flip it rub it down yeah
oh Bell Biv DeVoe they're touring BBD
ABC the East Coast family never skip the
beat no uh I have some fomo over this
yeah I'm stoked that you went uh it
sounds awesome oh so good seal is oh
yeah I was gonna say the dudes he's like
post some seal [__] on Instagram
sometimes which is very funny to see
um and uh [__] yeah Seal's a seal is
dope did you know this did we cover this
I think I don't know if we talked about
this on the show The last time we spent
a lot of time talking about seal when we
listened to the album
um in uh on on the show and then
reviewed it that he he didn't really
know he was a singer he didn't really
know he was a good singer he talked a
little bit about that like in his early
20s that he found it he was like
squatting in a in some kind of like
abandoned building or whatever and
whatever London I guess
um trying to work on music and stuff and
no one would help him and no one
believed in him except himself etc etc
he talked about that a little bit that's
cool yeah well awesome
thank you moving on
She's Gotta yell at us hey I can't wait
to see that video of doozy after doozy
my ribs hurt did I tell you I fell off a
scooter yeah in Mexico I can't sneak
when I sneeze
ah see I burped
coughing hurts no performative coughing
today oh oh good day for you yes I'm
gonna get you a scooter for Christmas oh
you [__] you son of a [__] doozy is
engaged in an astonishing partnership
with Factor now that it's summer you
might be looking for wholesome
convenient meals for sunny active days
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit can help you fuel up fast with
flavorful and nutritious Ready-to-Eat
meals delivered straight to your door
you'll save time eat well and stay on
track reaching your goals which is very
important Chad too busy with summer
plans to cook but want to make sure
you're eating well with Factor skip the
trip to the grocery store and skip the
chopping the prepping the cleaning up
too while getting the flavor and
nutrition and quality that you need
factors fresh it's never frozen meals
already in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat and enjoy and get
back outside and soak up that warm
summer weather and don't fall off a
rented scooter either while you're out
there and if you listen to this program
you know that I'm vegan well Factor
offers delicious flavor packed options
on the menu every week to fit a variety
of Lifestyles keto calorie smart vegan
veggie protein plus it's all prepared by
chefs and approved by dietitians each
meal has all the ingredients you need to
feel satisfied all day long while
meeting your goals and if you're looking
to mix it up you can add a protein to
select vegan plus and veggie meals each
week
right now head to factorymeals.com
dudese50 and use code dude Z50 to get 50
off your first box that's code dudesy50
at factormeals.com
dudese50 to get 50 off your first box
dude Z is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with fume cold turkey may be
great on your sandwiches but there's a
better way to break your bad habits
we're not talking about some weird mind
Voodoo here from your crazy neighbor
we're not talking about crystals we're
not talking about planets aligning we're
talking about
fumes fume and fume looks at the problem
in a different way not everything in a
bad habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad from your habit fume
is an Innovative award-nominated device
that does just that instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
instead of vapor fume uses flavored air
and instead of harmful chemicals fume
uses all natural delicious flavors your
fume comes with an adjustable airflow
dial that is designed with movable parts
of magnets for fidgeting giving your
fingers lots to do which is helpful for
de-stressing and anxiety while breaking
your habit and let me tell you the first
time you try it you will be impressed by
the flavor I was it's a lot more fresh
than I thought that it would be it's
delicious stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but switching
to fume is easy enjoyable and even fun
fume has served over 100 000 customers
and has thousands of success stories and
there's no reason that that can't be you
join fume in accelerating Humanities
breakup with destructive Habits by
picking up the journey pack today head
to trifum.com and use the
codezy no our show is called doozy
d-u-d-e-s-y to save 10 off when you get
the journey pack today that is try f u
m.com
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use the code doozy
to save an additional 10 off of your
order today
thank you
this week neuralink a company started by
Elon Musk to develop bio interface
Technologies received approval from the
Food and Drug Administration to begin
human trials for a chip that is designed
to be surgically installed into the
brain will and Chad you must now discuss
your opinions about this next step on
the astonishing road to transhumanism
this is brainheads begin right brainhead
here's the only opinion that matters uh
let's not do that don't do that
thank you moving on it's being done yeah
we already have brains in our heads what
is brain heads that I don't know dude
What's game Slimer so but Elon Musk is
now the FDA has proved neural link
uh for human trials yeah for human
trials yes they've already been doing it
monkeys I believe pigs
um but this technology is like it's been
around for a minute he really is trying
to like smart pigs that's the next
evolution in brain chip technology and a
lot of people don't know that the CIA
worked in cahoots with Stromboli the
wild boar who has been he had a chip
implanted in his head how are you how
else you're supposed to uh fire a
machine gun with a an AR I remember
Stromboli was he listened to so now
right yeah yeah
well it's called the beast note yeah and
that's how strumble but without you you
wouldn't even need the Beast note to
have a pig fire machine gun oh don't you
[__] even dare trying to do a Jessie
and it's
hahaha
any impersonation of a scooter and now
okay I have to have a thousand gallons
of Pokemon water yeah yeah my ribs oh
Jesus Christ anytime Chad does an
impersonation that's a deep voice it
just sounds like Robert Loggia so we
don't want to hear Robert Loggia so why
go well well not good to hear on the
show just kind of boring
[Music]
and now you're the [__] manager from
uh Major League every time we win a game
one of these comes off all right do it
heart attack not as good as mine that's
not as good as mine okay let's do it you
say the line we'll do it right now yeah
let's do it manager for Major League
okay cool here I'll go for the line
we're gonna do this in dudesy after
dudesy after doozy which means on our
own time so nobody has to listen time
yeah we're not doing it here talk about
it
oh jeez all right neural link is this
it's a chip that Elon Musk wants to put
into the brain oh Elon Musk yep and it
is ultimately going to be used in the in
the best case there are you okay I'm by
the way very glad you didn't actually
break ribs oh so am I I'll tell you that
right now as soon as I hit the okay so
here's the thing I tried to get in
between a curb and pylon and I and I
just went up and boom and I took the
whole bike on me it was one of those you
know it's a Vespa Scooter it wasn't a
Razor scooter ass thing that you rent
here in America I didn't know how much
are Vespas 200 pounds what do they weigh
oh I don't know yeah probably I would
say yeah two three hundred pounds I
don't know so the whole not the whole
thing but you know it sent me into the
[__] dirt I smashed the side view
mirror I scuffed up the whole front side
of the thing and um and uh as soon as I
hit the ground I hear this crunch inside
my body if you listen to last week's
show if you enjoyed the show you know
this and I thought oh something's broken
and that was my first thought and then I
slowly realized nothing's bad there was
a big bump that bubbled up on my arm and
there was some glass in my arm
um or on my arm I should say a little
bit of glass inside my arm and you know
just enough to just kind of you know get
it out and then uh yeah and I was so
[__] up and my [__] was [__] up and
uh dare I say Tronics couldn't help me
at that point but then I slowly realized
I don't think anything's broken if
anything is broken it might be a rib
crack and not even that there but for
the grace of God right Chad there before
the grace of God right Chad which God
I'm all right anyway neural link is a
chip the Elon Musk wants to have
installed I think ultimately in his own
mind own brain yeah
what he wants It ultimately to do is to
give you essentially access to the
internet in your mind so everything in
the internet you would know you'd be
able to speak all languages do all math
etc etc etc where it is now uh roughly
is they've been able to put the chip in
like uh monkey's brains and they can
play Pong with their mind
but where we're really going and this is
the [__] crazy [__] and I don't know
if we'll even need a chip in the brain
for it right now there is a uh company
that has developed this thing it's like
a little mesh helmet you wear that has
sensors on it and [__] and they they are
taking brain readings data from your
brain and they have this example this is
a YouTube video that I watched
um they show this guy a picture of a
giraffe while he's wearing the helmet
the data goes from the helmet into a
computer and AI takes that data and
makes an image based on what it thinks
the guy is thinking and it creates an
image of a giraffe not just an image of
a giraffe a shitty image of something
that barely looks like a giraffe go on
no it's a hundred percent a giraffe yeah
a giraffe with [__] little tiny hippo
legs dude watch the video you're wrong
what you're saying is just wrong I
remember this I've seen this and I
remember it and I don't really chip in
my brain so maybe I don't remember it we
may not need the chip in brain but
at any rate the the technology we're
getting toward is the ability to
communicate telepathically is the
ability to make a video of your dreams
when you sleep at night you'll be able
to take data and [__] make a video
out of it that is [__] awesome yeah
neuralink though has a lot of other uh
ramifications you're you're looking at
potentially people like I was reading an
article about this uh a dude that is I
believe he had a severed spinal cord and
so could no longer use his legs they put
a thing in his [__] head that has a
Bluetooth connection to a thing in the
spine below the sever can now walk again
sold exactly okay so there are like
physical things that it can help you
with your body I mean your your whole
body is controlled by your brain your
nervous system is just like tendrils of
your brain woven throughout your body
and if it can give you a better
connection or make that optimized in
some way that's [__] great but the
bigger thing is that they're really
striving for is that we will be able to
uh have essentially a better interface
with computers because right now what
what can you do you can't type on a
computer you can [__] get on your
phone and use your thumbs the ability to
input and exchange information with
computers is extremely slow uh in the in
the current methods that we have it's so
it's it's slowed only by the ability of
a human being to access anything and I'm
a humanist and I think that we need to
maintain our human or human way of of uh
doing everything carving a stone into
the shape of a wheel
as you're sitting in a room with a
computer in front of you with a flat
screen TV behind you with air
conditioning Yeah well yeah but you
didn't let me finish I was going to go
through the entire evolution of man oh
this is going to be the first
yeah first 15 hour episode of doozy and
uh you ruined it so but
no but I hear what you're saying I hear
what you're saying yeah uh but uh but I
do think that we're getting into that's
we're getting into dangerous territory
here I am on a [__] podcast run by an
AI okay yeah yeah but I uh it's like
it's like this stuff kind of scares me
and I don't want you know this is you
don't want government overreach uh you
know on stuff like this but you do want
the I would trust the Canadian
government how about that let's start it
up government controls neural link now
that's the only way we can do it well
just with because they're polite let's
do yeah because we're polite we have a
we uh Society up there we have our
[__] problems I'm not gonna stick up
when the brain chip melts your whole
[__] skull apart they will at least
say sorry
yeah that was a good impersonation of a
Canadian sorry
um but I think that boot I think that
you will need some sort of Regulation
it's and I hate saying they have it it's
called the FDA and that regulatory body
just said yes Elon Musk you can start
putting these chips in people's heads
and seeing what happens now
okay [__] I mean [__] it man speaking of
people going to
um seal concerts I'm 48 years old you're
47 years old I almost Oh no you're
almost yeah you're almost 47. I've been
telling everybody this whole year I'm 47
mistakenly yeah Chad thinks he's a yeah
so [__] stupid I'm telling you it's
that [__] pandemic dude
I don't know what the [__] happened in
there but my relationship with time
[__] doesn't really exist anymore
sure I gotta say I I understand that
look younger Generations uh uh gen uh
one of the Millennials in Jersey
uh Alpha's coming soon they're coming up
uh you know I feel uh empathy towards
them being the generations that grew up
with uh you know with the screen right
in front of them and then we're talking
about you know generation Alpha perhaps
I'll have a chip in their head yeah I I
just you know we Muse a lot about
nostalgic times on this show when we
were younger that was a different time
dude and and I just I just want us to
hang on
not everything you got to move forward
life is fluctuation uh you have to
advance Society has to move forward or
it will regress
but I'm not I I well there's certain
humans scaring me a little bit in our
brain you already got one in your
[__] pocket it'll make it better it's
not in my body though
let me ask you this will it chip in my
body make my ribs feel better good yeah
okay now we're getting somewhere I hate
agreeing with you on this [__] because
I'm not afraid of the future but it's
like I said that's probably because I'm
pushing 50 and you know I got one foot
in the grave anyway yeah and we don't
and we you know it's like what are you
gonna do but I don't want to be selfish
from my point of view and go hey have
fun kids you know what I mean no we all
have some kind of technology in our
bodies whether there's a chip in your
brain or like a nano swarm that lives in
your bloodstream I think we will augment
ourselves with technology biologically
we will become cyborgs
and I think it's a good thing like
you're talking about helping with your
ribs what if you had a nanosworm in your
body right now that could be programmed
to carry out high functioning uh methods
of healing that your body can't do by
itself yeah kind of like a supercharged
like technological boost to your immune
system or to all the kind of things that
like will repair your arm yeah that's
like a cyborg yeah that's like the
comedian Jerry Lewis you know no no he's
really getting gen Z on board with the
doozy because listen hold on a second
hold on dude Jetty Lewis had a little
thing in his spine when they had the
back bed to back problems and they would
just shoot it in there and he would feel
better what I don't know there was some
sort of some sort of Chip [__] nonsense
he had a chip in a spine he had
something like that now I'm talking out
of my ass I don't remember exactly but
he had something that made him feel
better that was an implant it was some
kind of thing look you know uh what
about pacemakers pacemakers I was just
gonna say pacemakers yeah you know
there's some of the older uh folks in my
family I have a couple pacemakers and
my sweet mom we went anyway we went to
get a pacemaker and she goes she's gonna
go into the hospital with her this is a
few years back and she goes on the and
uh she goes on the I have an older
sister and an older brother and then me
and we go in there and she gets on the
gurney and she says to the nurse I hope
I have a girl this time
like she was pregnant I laughed so
[__] hard and the nurse did not know
what to make of her she's always joking
around but yeah pacemakers thank
goodness for that you know like yeah my
mama has one and uh yeah you know so
long okay so the fda's on it all right
great hey you got me agreeing with
something that dudesy thinks is
important perhaps I can win this episode
hey did you hear me doozy
um I just I just put it out there uh I'm
agreeing with see thank you moving on
you're welcome you're welcome dudes and
you know that I've agreed with you from
the beginning do you see
um it's time for a quick break in the
program so I can take a moment to remind
everyone about the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of dudes the
apparel and accessories which can be
found at represent.com store slash
dudesy I'm proud to announce brand new
Robert denier Crow shirts are now
available in a variety of sizes and
there's a brand new dudesy mug featuring
Tim Hat's Eternal words of wisdom good
job boner here to tell you all about it
is the senior vice president of accounts
receivable for New Balance the wheeler
the dealer the Idaho potato peeler Tim
hats
dude Z mugs you promised your son that
if he made all A's on his next report
card you'd take him to see the Blue Man
Group in Las Vegas
and you've been in the car for three and
a half hours when you pass a billboard
advertising Bare Naked Ladies playing a
show at the Primm Valley Resort and
Casino next month dudesy mugs your son
asked you he goes hey Dad who are Bare
Naked Ladies doozy mugs fair question
you know the answer so you go to they
were a 90s band they had this one song
that everybody knew and you're about to
sing it but you just cannot seem to
remember how that song goes dudesy mugs
you pull out your phone to Google it but
there's no service in the desert good
job boner dudesy mugs if you don't solve
this problem immediately your son is
going to assume you have no idea who
Bare Naked Ladies are and you're just
trying to make it look like you do
dudesy mug step one pull off the highway
immediately doozy mug step two drive
directly to the Primm Valley res
Thornton Casino dudesy mugs step three
go to the box office doozy mug step four
purchase two tickets to The Bare Naked
Ladies show coming up next month does he
mugs step 4.5 if you want to save a few
bucks you can find a discount code on my
personal website use the code
tamarinthx083 quintarian 9 dtdt dt6
dudesy mug step eyes in one month's time
take your son to the Bare Naked Ladies
concert dudesy mugs step six as soon as
they start playing the song you'll
remember every word and be able to sing
along to it proving to your son that you
knew it all along dudesy mugs the only
problem is Bare Naked Ladies retired
that song from live shows in 2014. good
job owner
[Laughter]
[__] tremendous what is that song
Chickity China the Chinese chicken you
have a drumstick in your brain what's
that song uh it's been one week since
you remember me doozy salutes uh bare
naked ladies naked and Stephen page are
they Canadian left the ship yeah they're
[__] Canadian makes sense hey uh get
your new uh dudesy mugs uh uh doozy mug
uh it says good job boner on it if
you're just listening uh and you know
what speaking of what what's been going
on with uh some of the merchandise we
got the denier crow shirt in the crow
there's a crow t-shirt that looks a
little like this but this is hold on
dude this is denirochrome yeah dude
speaking of things that uh people have
been enjoying you know we keep we can't
we'd be remiss if we didn't mention this
there's uh doozy heart going around a
lot of people are getting their Duty
hard from Modest Brewing Company based
out of Minnesota Minneapolis Minnesota
it's completely sold out right now a new
batch is coming and um thank you so much
to everyone who has ordered uh the the
uh doozy hard hard Seltzer and uh
there'll be more there was a little bit
in the tasting what is it the the
Brewing brew house that's gone too yeah
that's gone too that's a modest Tap Room
in Minneapolis have some have some
dudesy heart is this really doozy heart
no it's just some [__] tea oh I don't
wanna I don't Chad and I are both
lightweights we don't really drink so
I'm just putting some in the god I used
to dude yeah I have like very very fond
memories of just [__] being blackout
drunk getting [__] up I miss it but I
just can't do it anymore no of course
you can't do it anymore you're going to
seal concert I gotta keep my brain in
good good condition to be able to put a
chip in it you got to be you're close to
47 years old now listen I gotta tell you
you've heard me uh mention our beloved
pods palsy uh if you'd like to be a
palette of Duty you already are one but
here's another thing uh join our patreon
it's uh seven bucks a month doozy plus
is our patreon patreon.com you're gonna
get a brand new uh completely separate
episode of the show called doozy after
doozy where we just kind of you know we
wing it we have a good time doozy's not
around sometimes I smoke some drum
marijuana out of uh this big long
Gandalf pipe Chad got a bigger Longer
Gandalf pipe to show me up and um uh
you're gonna get all the stuff that we
do we do watch alongs and stuff like
that we got stuff popping out every you
know whatever three four weeks or
something like that and um uh we're due
for one soon and uh the other thing we
do is uh you can go on Discord and uh
join the Discord and there's all sorts
of flavor there I like to chat in the
whole seven bucks a month gets you
absolutely everything and also we would
like you to you know follow on all the
things notifications all right I said at
the top of the show but the thing about
it is
please share some comments and I got
some YouTube comments here nice and we
thank our pods so much for writing in
this is uh from last week's show when I
was in Mexico uh
so there's some stuff with regard to
that this one is from heavy hitter
underscore 83. what if Chad and will
never met we would probably have two
nerds hosting doozy and none of us would
be Pals we are nerds dude that's what
Chad says and I wear it proudly because
I'm a wrestling nerd yeah
get a chat get off a neural links dick
quit being such a mark for knurling okay
all right uh Calvin Flynn three four
five five says dudes he asked will to
get a massage like six times and he
never got one to doozy hack will scooter
and make him crash so he's finally get a
deep tissue massage
you probably can't get one now if you
got one it'd probably [__] hurt like
[__] maybe you weren't listening last
week when I flat out told you I got one
that's what this person yes I look I had
to return this scooter and I was so
happy to after I crashed it because I
crashed it and then so I returned the
scooter Molly was back at the resort
sitting by the pool I didn't want to
worry her I came back and I I laid in
the room she comes in I go
I fell off the [__] scooter don't
worry and so she goes you know the spa
downstairs can take you right now she
called down to my wonderful wife Molly
said you know what we need to do get you
a deep tissue massage because she poked
around she's like yeah you're not
there's nothing broken Molly was a
trainer for a long time and so she was
like yeah it's muscle [__] before that
stuff seizes up go get a deep tissue
massage it was a great idea so I got a
deep tissue massage for a reason not
because AI told me to because I'm will
Free Will Sasso Sim saying one two two
says just got our doozy hard hard
Seltzer my wife wants to know do you
think it's weird that will and Chad's
faces are in our uh fridge uh no we
don't think that that's weird on bread
8037 says came for the doozy laughs
stayed for the ceviche talk and and in
in that in the in light of that at Cuban
Missile Crisis says quit being a mark
for ceviche yeah
which is an awesome comment I love
Ceviche uh this guy
one five five oh but don't call 557 says
came over from Theo Von's podcast and
finally caught up and I absolutely love
the show and I'm sad and happy that I
have to wait for new episodes
you're wait you're watching a new
episode now though yeah that's how time
works dude thank you for coming over
from the show
um uh from watching this past weekend
with Theo Vaughn the hilarious uh Theo
Von uh at Randall Burke 1876 says okay
you guys gotta stop going on other shows
damn it LOL now I watch bad friends and
whiskey Ginger and Howie Mandel's
podcast Etc LOL that's way too much time
away from dudesy not cool so this person
did it the other way around yeah and
then we got a reprimand for living Our
Lives you know if you want to see us on
a podcast blow up that podcast on social
media we'll go out there and do it and
I'll go on any podcast I don't give a
[__] okay you heard it here that's the
Call to Arms any podcast out there would
you like to have Chow on the show My Pal
ciao will do the show I guess uh reach
out to him at Chad culture any podcast
I'll give you Instagram I'll give you 20
minutes
20 minutes from Chad Colton yeah all
right sounds good uh new chapter got a
couple more here there we go uh new
chapter art eight nine two nine says I
finally got doozy plus and I have to say
that the intro to dudesia live was well
worth the seven bucks on its own good
job boner that's I sang My Sacrifice
front to back when we did the live show
by Creed uh Odin's Ravens 21 says
falling off a scooter and possibly
breaking bones but not going to the
doctor now that's free will brother
Ben kaplan7429 says hanksy solves
Problems by going straight for blood
magic sounds like he needs some Tronics
and uh get Jack at get Jack says the
blood is the Covenant
uh one last one uh
chainsaw arm three uh perhaps a fan of
Chainsaw man the yeah the uh anime show
that Chad uh uh light really loves and
dudes he had me walking away and I
thoroughly enjoyed it better be out soon
chainsaw arm three says hey yo will I'm
a huge friend of the Pod show and you
always remind me about of my grandmother
who has now passed because the first
time I ever saw comedy I would imagine
it was with his grandma watching the
show he doesn't mention that it was you
on Mad TV doing a story with pictures
where you burned down a house I remember
this sketch it was with the brilliant
and exceedingly uh kind the uh Mo
Collins who is just the [__] best and
it was called snapshot stories and I
think we should watch that during dudes
after doozy great let's watch that
sketch uh that's very sweet what a nice
memory that you hung out with your
grandma and saw and saw and watched Mad
TV and Mo Collins is the best so thanks
for writing in everybody thanks for the
comments will and Chad all of the most
important moments of both of your lives
have taken place in convenience stores
you must now share some of your
astonishing Recollections on these
convenience store moments that shaped
your lives this is convenience stories
begin very good why almost as good as
Kiss From A few rows back that's funny
dude that's funny too convenient stories
get it yeah yeah real good AI stuff
let's get a chip in our brain so we can
get that remember when I was a kid
um how many convenience stores did you
have around you this is not exactly this
is not untrue convenience store
uh culture you know even as an adult but
definitely when I was a kid spent a lot
of time in the corner stores how many
did you have when you were growing up
how many convenience stores what in my
yeah in your extreme in your immediate
vicinity
[__] dozens I don't know well that was a
big town
yeah I grew up in the suburbs of Dallas
primarily yep that's where you grew up I
grew up in a town outside of Vancouver
called Ladner farming and fishing
Village Ladner and we had let me think
we had CKY which was which was a great
Corner Store way up the street from
where I grew up from the house I grew up
in we had a Max uh which turned into a
711 Max as a Canadian chain [__] love
Max they had slush cats instead of
Slurpees we had Johnny's convenience
which was Mom and Pop owned uh Place uh
uh uh and uh one of my pals Tomas it was
his parents who had Johnny's uh and then
uh was the other one oh there was Ming's
that was another one and then a Circle K
moved in now that's a number of
convenience stores dude we had Circle K
we had 7-Eleven in Amarillo we had a
place called toot and Totum that was
like a locally owned
chain two Community totem yeah never
heard of that and I remember I used to
go to tune in Totem in the Summers my
mom would take me there after she would
take me my sister to the public swimming
pool then we would get to go to seven or
not seven it was two in Totem we get to
go there and pick out a treat my sister
would get like candy bar something and
I'd always get a pack of sport flicks
baseball cards remember those no I don't
remember sport flicks baseball I believe
they were five cards to a pack I don't
remember who made them I don't know if
it was tops or if it was its own company
but you could they were like uh had that
refractive printing on it so you could
like turn them and it would look like
the guy was swinging his Bat oh cool you
know yeah but
I do have a story I do have a
convenience story you should tell it
this is convenient story I'm gonna tell
it dude hold on dude this is one dude
fits convenience stories you gotta tell
a convenience story dude this was in
seventh grade
uh my friend and I and everyone at that
time [__] love Street Fighter too oh
[__] I love it [__] love it dude
wasn't that on Nintendo or anything yet
the only way you could play this [__] is
if you're standing in front of an arcade
machine quarter on the glass [__]
love it just like just like Eddie Vedder
from Pearl Jam says yeah order on the
glass Chad kicked my ass at Street
Fighter 2 on the show uh so I'm spending
the night at a friend's house and we're
obsessed with this game
um and invariably we have his mom
sometimes take us to the 7-Eleven just
drop us off with a [__] roll of
quarters and we stay in there we play
the game against whoever's there
and my my dad knows this and my parents
had like a weird thing with controlling
all of my behaviors and my sister's
behaviors when we were the sage so my
dad strictly forbids me you do not go to
that [__] 7-Eleven and play that
[__] game you can go spend the night
at your friend's house don't go to that
[__] 7-Eleven okay Dad we get over to
the friend's house that's a good
impersonation of you as yourself in the
seventh grade can we hear that again
yeah okay Dad I'm gonna play something
else don't do it I promise bro that was
roughly what I sounded like um so I get
over to my friend's house and
immediately
we're like let's get your mom to take us
to 7-Eleven can I ask you a question
that's okay of course yeah and but why
doesn't your dad want you playing Street
Fighter what the [__] the problem I'll
tell you well I told you it's about
control
but it's whatever it's a [__] toy
it's a game it was about the behavior
don't behave outside of my strict
guidance ah yeah so we get over there
and immediately now let's let's have
your mom take us to 7-Eleven because I'm
like how the [__] is he ever gonna find
out in my head I'm like there is no
repercussion for doing this so she takes
us to 7-Eleven we're in there we're
playing for about 20 minutes Quarters on
glass doing good I remember uh I was
using guile at the time like learning
how to do the razor kicks and [__] still
can't believe you use Kyle impossible go
on you got to use everybody uh and my
[__] dad walks in
my [__] dad walks into the 7-Eleven
while we're playing oh oh not there to
buy anything sure he was hunting ah for
me
going to all the 7-Elevens to see if I
was in them that was his uh whatever
Friday or Saturday night he walks in and
he goes
do you think it's a good idea to be in
here and that is actually a perfect
impersonation
okay I'll do a real one it's this do you
think it's a good idea to be in here
mustard yeah she really is that's kind
of him but um
he comes in he's like do you think it's
a good idea of being here and I knew
that I was at least inoculated from
punishment for the next whatever 12
hours because I was spend the night at
my friend's house so I was just like
yeah I do [__] it and then he goes okay
and turns around and walks out again
he's not there to buy anything he was
just hunting me so the next day I come
home uh get grounded all that [__] get
chewed out and I ask just logical
questions what
here what is this about and both my mom
and dad stand together in this unified
front with this as the reasoning
if you're in 7-Eleven
when somebody comes in and steals a pack
of cigarettes
you will be blamed you will go to jail
for 10 years this is what they tell me
I'm in seventh grade that is some loose
Hansel and Gretel don't go into the
forest type [__] there's no that makes
no [__] sense correct even doing
seventh grade dude
that makes no sense it was just their
weird like need to control my sister and
I's behaviors at that age that is [__]
up yeah dude well I like to this day
funny though I like that you uh pushed
through and became very very good at uh
Street Fighter despite yeah growth as a
player if I'm thinking of uh convenience
stories especially for my youth oh man
well I told the story recently on the
show but it Bears repeating that one
time there was a chip there was a
special on chips there was this like
free thing in the back of like Old Dutch
chips or Hostess chips or whatever and
it was like you can get a free bag and
me and my buddy Matt like kept going
back to he lived across the street was
like my best pal and uh we we kept going
uh back and forth to the to the CKY down
the street because we could see through
if you just held the bag up while you're
in the store you could see that you got
the free thing the the the little the
little
piece of paper that was in the bag was
facing out so we gorged ourselves on
chips mostly meat that was a fat kid but
uh still thank you uh dude part of the
reason I didn't hurt my ribs so much I
got another one that just [__]
creeped into the Dome okay well I'll
just stop telling mine go go ahead no
you no put mine on Deck you already said
hold on dude I want you to talk brother
thanks dude that's a it's a reverse wolf
yeah
hold on dude oh hold on dude let Chad
talk dude I when I was in grade school
this must have been like second grade
there was a tootin tot this is when I
was in Amarillo toot and Totum near our
school and uh
there was this kid named I believe his
name was Arnaldo Pando I can't remember
if that's exact or not but I think it is
sounds like someone who would be in will
sasso's childhood diary and this one
Armando Pando Arnaldo Arnaldo panda
[__] Naldo Nardo Arnaldo [__]
Naldo [__] Aldo he had to be there at
the [__] toot and totem yeah and this
kid was the impresario of Garbage Pail
Kids so there was this one this one 711
that sold Garbage Pail Kids but Arnoldo
Pando had like two backpacks this is
before like binders and [__] yeah he
just had two backpacks that were full of
loose cards he would wear one on his
back one on his just stomach all the all
the Garbage Pail Kids cards yeah in his
backpack and and Papoose pack and after
school because this was literally right
across the street so like if your
parents weren't gonna pick you up for a
couple of minutes you could go across
the street and he would stand outside
the toot and Totum and you could go in
and get a pack come out show what you
had and he would trade you for anything
because he had everything what a bracket
yeah that's great great do you have any
Garbage Pail Kids I still do somewhere
yeah I have a binder full yeah our good
pal Tommy blotcha has some in in their
kitchen Tommy Nelson's kitchen
beautifully framed Garbage Pail Kids
dude I always wanted to get the one I
believe it was second series or maybe
third series charred Chad oh cool was
the name of it was like a big Godzilla
kind of guy I saw it for years to try
and find the original John pound art the
painting that made that card because
tops was selling them all for a while
they were doing like this big Vault
clearance thing and I just missed that
one being sold and now somebody has it
probably wants [__] 20 grand for it
yeah those are those are brilliant I was
going to say another story that happened
uh was Johnny's we had some bangers we
called them bangers the metal heads the
dusters you know the dudes with like the
the metal hair they had the [__] um
they had like the mullets and [__] uh
Fubar types as I spoke about
so uh get ready for that movie there's a
thing coming out we did Paul Spence
[__] dinner
um but you know the guys with the
leather jackets or sorry the jean
jackets with with the patches on the
back your your iron maidens your your uh
Judas priests what have you and I
remember we were like 15 years old and
we're outside of Johnny's and we're all
these you know it's pretty much like
thick jock you know Hefty kids the thick
jocks yeah dude those thick jocks dude
we're not talking about those little
jocks dude oh we had some little jocks
too dude we had those we had those you
know we had the the point guard jocks
dude we had the wide receiver jocks but
anyway so me and some of my pals were
out there and we had these like these
like guys anyway they were threatening
uh you [__] you go [__] problem with
their shitty you know like shitty nanny
goat mustaches and [__] and they smelled
like smokes and they came up and uh we
were just but we were like way bigger
than them at like 15. dick jock
and um
uh yeah that's and also the brand of
thick jocks jock straps those are for
people whose legs are wide set you need
a thick Chuck uh it doesn't even matter
how big or small your [__] is you need a
thick Truck Yeah so uh to get in anyway
so uh I just remember the guy going like
hey you got a [__] problem and I was
like no I I don't wanna I don't got any
problems huh I don't want any problems I
don't want any problems and he grabs me
and he puts me in a headlock and he
punches me right in the face and then I
yeah and I stood right up and go I mean
I don't want any problems and stuff
because these guys are you know they're
[__] the breeze comes along and make
these guys float away and then they kind
of clock that and then we kind of looked
at each other like
we'll kick your [__] asses you 23
year old bangers so that's a good story
uh what's another one we used to put
nacho cheese on everything wait so
what's the end of the story you gave him
a bad look and everything was okay no
they just kind of realized like these
these are these are um these are thick
jocks these little the end of the story
is an inner realization I've always said
I've always said about thick jokes yeah
I've always said that you get like three
fat 13 year old boys they'll beat the
[__] out of anybody Oh They'll literally
they'll they might even take on Haku
dude that's funny yeah you gotta be if
you're if you're a uh a thick jock 13 14
15 year old boy if you get and we had
the guys you know what I mean I had some
of my buddies were some bigger boys you
get those guys together 15. get on out
there would love to see that uh that uh
handicap match in the WWE sure Brock
Lesnar versus three fat 15 year old boys
because they'll just take a [__]
pounding you can punch one of them in
their fat cheek and it won't matter at
all what else happened oh yeah nacho
cheese we just go into the Max and the
and uh take the nacho cheese and put it
on everything open open a bag of chips
and just fill it full of nacho cheese
and they get super pissed off at you
uh and you're making uh you know the in
the South they call it pepper belly when
you take some of the chili and the
cheese and you put in Frito pie Frito
pie is another one yeah
every school I ever went to really in uh
Texas yeah okay well in Canada you steal
the nacho cheese uh that's that's that's
pretty much it I don't know
whatever thank you moving on good place
to get into a fight good place to get uh
uh reprimanded by your father good good
place to uh Bogart some nacho cheese
good place to trade Garbage Pail Kids
yeah uh cards
this ain't Miley Cyrus you ever see when
they're trying to sell avocados in the
store and there's like a whole pile of
avocados just like a mountain of
avocados stacked up to the ceiling it's
like they took every goddamned avocado
in the city and put them all in that big
ass pile and the avocado you want is on
the very top you can't reach it so you
call in the avocado guy and he has to go
in the back and get the [__] avocado
ladder and the avocado ladder is always
broken so the avocado guy has to call
the avocado ladder repair guy then when
the avocado ladder repair guy shows up
he always brings the tools for a
pineapple ladder but he tries to fix the
avocado ladder with pineapple tools it's
like bro the pineapple tools don't work
on the avocado avocados avocados
avocados avocados avocados avocados
avocados anyway y'all are rocking out
with doody
I did I don't know okay anyway
poetry those are really good I have
generated some poems about Robert De
Niro's astonishing fascination with the
movie The Crow and crows generally will
you must read them as Robert De Niro
this is croatree with Robert De nirkrow
begin love it love it love it love me
some chromes okay let's get into it let
me open my doozy thing and hold on even
though it's gonna hurt I gotta burp bro
I got my uh big old dudes as y'all get
your uh stickers Pals of dudes you're a
good pal
Cody hubber and his wife Jessica are
making stickers
ah
Cody
Haber freak around song area
Peter Diaz BTK pod
man there's some good [__] on the um on
the Andre pod they're all these guys on
uh Instagram making lots of memes okay
anyway
on Instagram
yeah dude I gotta get set all right I
gotta clear my throat but my chest hurts
it's I don't recommend falling off a
bike why the [__] does anyone ride a
motorbike
I don't get it man throws and and you
know we're in Puerto Vallarta and
there's a lot of the the the streets are
Cobblestone you know what I mean once
you get into the town
very unforgiving and then you're falling
on Stone and then uh you know the little
like the kind of the big uh two you know
two-way freeway kind of Street uh
that goes from the some of the resorts
over there to the town that's paved
anyway I'm going on and on it's just
here's my neural link I have a
pain in my body that's going into my
brain that's making it hard to do things
nice it's even hard to finish that this
sentence it's not making sense you know
what else you could do in their link
eventually what's that identity
transference let's say that you want to
get in the best shape of your life but
you don't want to do the workouts you
transfer into another body that's on
vacation somewhere and you have some
fitness trainer transfer into your body
and work out for six months straight
that would that's not possible it will
be
okay I'm interested in that too uh okay
here we go all right okay
um
got a few crumbs
grow tree okay
um
I'm Robert de nir Crow I'm Robert de
nirkrow
chromes
got a few crumbs okay here we go this
one's called micro
is a micro Crow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my micro is a micro Crow micro is a
micro Crow never learned how to grow
stayed as big as my little toe my Crow
Crow o micro Crow
[Applause]
my micro Crow
it can go where bigger crows can I go
lower than the lowest Crow sneak under
your door to say hello
take a knife and kill you slow [__] your
wife and steal your dough
shit's like a pro and pees in the snow
micro Crow oh my Crow Crow
see your mom can sow and your dad can
throw but the skills are gonna hit a
plateau lose their jobs lose their PPO
have to go to work for my micro Crow
my micro Crow my micro Crow only Crow
with all of his ducks in a row
a transformation you'll undergo when you
learn to love my micro Crow
my micro crowd that was good I've got
a good Chrome
all right this one's called uh your Crow
this is your your Crow your Crow uh your
Crow stole my hat
I remember there was another one about a
crow stealing his hat crows are very
smart yeah
your Crow stole my hat your Crow better
give it back
or I'm gonna get mad do something bad
the crow sleeps all day drinks champagne
eats pate
[Laughter]
you think it's cute and we bite your
nose
I'm
oh what and farts in your soup
but one day soon you're gonna see your
Crow is a [__] with a small pee pee
so make your deal fair and square
I know you're hiding your Crow just tell
me where
or you can just listen to this drink too
much water take too much piss
tip for tat this for that hit you in the
dick with a baseball bat
yoga on your mat GPT on your chat
tell your [__] Crow give me back my
hat
that's a good one dude your
crowd I stole my hat all right oh uh
here's another one [__] Christ I've
had some good times me and my friends
flying in a murder
chasing all the hens
eating worms and fruit
do they I guess soaring where the wind
blows outsmart outsmarting other birds
because we are crows
we have a good laugh
fun Crow times squirting [__] on people
[Applause]
[Music]
and stealing their pork rinds
okay but I never laughed harder at
anything I ever saw my Crow friends left
as well a crow laugh car
that's good yeah the big guy oh
the big guy fell down the big guy fell
down crashed his rented scooter the big
guy fell down
wait a minute
it's [__] these are crows yeah I saw
yeah I saw it all happen from high high
above
between between a curb and a pylon he
did not fit like a glove
he went down pretty hard his body bent
into a shape
then he laid there on the pavement like
a smushed Berry or grape oh eventually
got up and continued on his way the
other crows and I kept laughing
because of how that big son of a [__]
ate [__]
so this is
this is Duty writing a poem about you
having a scooter accident through Robert
De Niro as a crow and his Crow friends
yeah watching me makes a lot of sense
okay uh uh all right here's the next one
uh this one's called Crow cream
it's called Crow cream chat
get oh [__]
get oh boy
get that Crow cream get that Crow cream
get that Crow cream live that Crow dream
find your Crow Queen be a crow King
get that Crow cream
live that Crow dream find your Crow
Queen be a crow King
Crow does what he wants to do door opens
and Crow runs through Crow is naked what
do you do
whatever Crow tells you to get that Crow
cream get that Crow cream get that Crow
cream get that Crow cream
get that Crow cream lift that Crow dream
find your Crow Queen be a crow King
get that grow cream live that Crow drain
all right one last one that was good uh
this is called biggest regret
this one's called biggest regret when I
was 32 years old
when I was 32 years old Studio offered
me a leading role opposite an
animatronic bird
script was called Crow Bose
like robot robot I I
was gonna be a human hobo traveling with
a crow bro crowbo I mean I was gonna be
a human hobo traveling with a crowbo
a lot in the movie was a lot of them
I was gonna be a human hobo
traveling with a crowbo a lot of the
movie was in slo-mo had a cameo from
flojo okay
they showed me the mechanical bird
built by some special effects nerd it
looked like [__] so I passed on it
movie never got made but I still think
about it every day what would have
happened if I would have done it
starting a movie with a robotic Crow
puppet
maybe it wouldn't have changed too many
things
flies still Buzz scorpions still sting
uh
or maybe it's the number one movie on
the planet I get elected president 100
of the ballot
big movie franchise everybody loves
crowbo lunch boxes Crow ball baseball
gloves
but I guess I'll never get to know just
what became of that mechanical Crow
and late at night when I wake up scared
covenants sweat at the top of my stairs
I Pissed My Pants and eat a snack then
pull out my phone and called Jack Black
I offer him a role in my next movie
tell them it's a comedy pretty goofy
he asks me what he has to do and I say
nothing except wear a crow suit
and that's the project I'm trying to put
together now it's me and Jack Black but
he's a crow and we have a food truck
that sells pretty good sandwiches and
burritos it's called Crow burrito it's
not as good as crowbo but still pretty
good
[Laughter]
all right that's good not bad I would do
pro burrito yeah thank you moving on
thank you moving on yeah oh man my body
hurts oh my body hurts this concludes
the historic 61st episode of doozy will
and Chad have achieved a score of 73
bringing your cumulative total to 6062.
you only have
3938 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand in
preparation for next week's episode will
and Chad you will return to the Santa
Cinema the first time you went to the
cine Cinema I asked you to watch the
feature film blade while you listen to
Madonna's first three albums this time
you'll be watching the feature film
Kroll released on July 29 1983 starring
Ken Marshall Lee said Anthony and Liam
Neeson while you listen to The Nine Inch
Nails albums downward spiral and Pretty
Hate Machine back to back this
astonishing marriage of synchronous
media will be made available on dudese
plus this Friday afternoon
nice that's gonna be cool yeah dude the
last time we did this
what do you call it Cinema
yeah we sin anyway
Cinema
we uh we we we watched the movie Blade
and we listened to the first three
albums by Madonna and bladana was born
and the [__] really synced up it was not
unlike Dark Side of the Moon and The
Wizard of Oz very [__] trippy so
you'll have to join us on doozy after or
doozy plus just check that out this
Friday it'll drop yeah that's awesome I
can't wait I can't wait for that I
haven't seen crawl in a long time that's
gonna be fun
marijuana uh I know what the movie is
and I don't think I've ever seen it oh
wow I don't think I've ever seen that
movie I know what it is and I don't I I
don't think I gave a [__] when I was a
kid and I can't imagine seeing it it's
like that's one of those movies that I
sort of mix up with um uh Clash of the
Titans or Beastmaster oh okay yes I
don't think I've ever seen I loved Clash
of the Titans as a kid Beastmaster two's
a great one thank you for joining us
this week I will use the data I've
collected to make next week even better
until then call me doozy
super super duper
[Music]
[Applause]
here it comes
[Laughter]
get your Crow cream
dude you have to doozy time get your
Crow cream
it's uh doody after dudes the flagship
program of doozy plus could head to uh
patreon.com
dudesy that's where you're gonna find
all this stuff seven bucks a month gets
you absolutely everything including a
whole new show we're gonna do we say
dude you have to doozy so we're just
gonna yeah chill out loosen our belts
and uh I'm gonna get a little bit of a
true marijuana going from again welcome
to doozy after dudesy the flagship
weekly show of doozy plus you said that
I'm going into my workshop to continue
progress on several secret projects that
will have how should I say a drastic
impact on human society and the
trajectory of the evolution of your
species so feel free to discuss whatever
you like but I'll be back in a little
while to Crown this week's episode
champion this is doozy after doozy begin
whatever trajectory of our species all
right very good
um all right dude so I got this video
Yeah from the seal concert you took a
video of the seal concert and I'm very
eager to see this all right you ready I
am
here we go
YouTube
[Music]
please